Voiceover:The three points plotted below
are on the graph of y is
equal to b to the x power.
Based only on these three points,
plot the three corresponding points
that must be on the graph
of y is equal to log base b of x
by clicking on the graph.
I've actually copy and pasted this problem
on my little scratch
pad so I can mark it up
a little bit.
What is this first function?
This first function is telling us
so x, and this is y is
equal to b to the x power.
When x is equal to
zero, y is equal to one.
That's this point right over here.
When x is equal to one, b to the one power
or b to the first power is equal to four.
y is equal to four.
Another way of thinking of this
y or four is equal to b to the first power
and actually we can do
[said] must be four.
That's this point right over there.
This point is telling us
that b to the second power
is equal to 16.
When x is equal to two,
b to the second power, y is equal to 16.
Now we want to plot the
three corresponding points
on this function.
Let me draw another table here.
Now it's essentially the inverse function
where this is going to be x
and we want to calculate y
is equal to log base b of x.
What are the possibilities here?
What I want to do is think ...
Let's take these values
because these are
essentially inverse functions
log is the inverse of exponents.
If we take the points one, four, and 16.
What is y going to be here?
y is going to be log base b of one.
This is saying what power
I need to raise b to
to get to one.
If we assume that b is non zero
and that's a reasonable assumption
because b to different
powers are non zero,
this is going to be
zero for any non zero b.
This is going to be zero
right there, over here.
We have the point one comma zero,
so it's that point over there.
Notice this point
corresponds to this point,
we have essentially
swapped the x's and y's.
In general when you're taking an inverse
you're going to reflect over
the line, y is equal to x
and this is clearly
reflection over that line.
Now let's look over here,
when x is equal to four
what is log base b of four.
What is the power I need to raise b to
to get to four.
We see right over here,
b to the first power is equal to four.
We already figured that out,
when I take b to the first
power is equal to four.
This right over here is
going to be equal to one.
When x is equal to
four, y is equal to one.
Notice once again, it is
a reflection over the line
y is equal to x.
When x is equal to 16
then y is equal to log base b of 16.
The power I need to
raise b to, to get to 16.
Well we already know,
if we take b squared, we get to 16,
so this is equal to two.
When x is equal to 16, y is equal to two.
Notice we essentially just
swapped the x and y values
for each of these points.
This is y, this is a reflection
over the line y is equal to x.
Now, let's actually do that
on the actual interface.
The whole reason is to
give you this appreciation
that these are inverse
functions of each other.
Let's plot the points.
That point corresponded to that point,
so x zero, y one
corresponds to x one, y zero.
Here x is one, y is four
that corresponds to x four, y one.
Here x is two, y is 16
that corresponds to x 16, y is two.
We got it right.